it's October which means Halloween is
looming and overwatch is getting into
the spirit pun totally intended I'm Tony
and this is your seasonal gamespot news
update / watches next event is here and
it's called Halloween terror loot boxes
have been replaced with jack-o'-lanterns
but they contain the same sweet prizes
Halloween terror includes over 100 new
cosmetic items including skins sprays
emotes victory poses and more
Frankenstein road hog and pumpkin head
reaper look particularly spooky but the
biggest addition is the new brawl a
totally different PvE game mode called
junkin steins revenge picture horde mode
but with zombie robots you'll hop into
the role of Anna as The Alchemist Hanzo
as the archer McCree as the gunslinger
or soldier 76 as the well as the soldier
Blizzard has also released a companion
comic which goes into more detail about
dr. junkin Stein and his creations
overwatch is Halloween terra runs until
november first so you have until then to
gather up as many jaco Luke boxes as you
can this is over watches second themed
event after the Summer Games just a few
months ago fingers are still crossed for
a Santa Claus torbjorn in December to
keep up with all the latest overwatch
news you're already in the right place